[Musica]
[Applauso]
allora voglio raccontarvi un po cosa mi
è successo quando ero piccolo intanto
quando era piccolo era un bambino come
gli altri e avevo una forte passione mi
piaceva giocare a calcio infatti in una
squadra di calcio insieme agli amici e
ci divertivamo la domenica
facevamo la partita e il lunedì
mercoledì e venerdì avevamo gli
allenamenti una sera però dopo un
allenamento sono tornato a casa un forte
molto forte dolore parte anche un carnet
tacco destro
inizialmente si pensava fosse semplice
troppo muscolare e che nel giro di un
mese tutto è sempre passato in realtà
non è stato così che passavo circa un
mese e il dolore è rimasto lo stesso ma
se oggi contano altra cosa avevo sempre
che andava e veniva è sempre questo
porto deluderemo
così sono tornato all'ospedale per
quanto d'analisi e 6 scoperto una cosa
avevo un tumore al fegato
l'unica cosa che si poteva fare era
trasferito a palermo perché qui in
toscana non era possibile effettuare il
trapianto al fegato e il pover armi era
un piccolo sapevo neanche cosa vuol dire
la parola trapianto l'unica cosa che
volevo era tornare a casa
e giocare con i miei amici come sempre
fatto arriva il 14 marzo del 2009 e si
parte per andare giù in sicilia a
effettuare il trapianto di fegato
il nodo canto durato circa 10 12 ore e
per fortuna è andato tutto bene
dopo 40 giorni dall'intervento
finalmente torno a casa e pensavo era
tutto finito
dopo un anno ci dica allora iniziava a
giocare al calcio ha visto raggio varie
nuove intanto vola nella squadra sono
anche con i miei amici
solo che all'età di 11 anni ne arriva
una brutta notizia
entravo a giocare a livello politico e
le regole del calcio e prevedono i
trapiantati non possono giovare a
livello agonistico
quindi pensavo di essere morto in sé
stante tentato un anno a piangere quale
tutti i giorni
quarto il piacere dopo questa pur tra
pizza telesca è passato un anno un anno
e mezzo
decido di avventurarmi una nuova
passione le single
avevo comprato scarico lì per caso
perché era da un pò di una mamma è
deciso di comprare uno skateboard
da quando ho comprato quelle skateboard
sono stato uscivo la mattina alle 10 e
finalmente ci contavo su per skateboard
denaro caso maggio allegro cibo è
presente al tavolo scrivo questa è la
giornata si descrive aver preso il
controllo di chi volevo soltanto quello
nel 2013
quindici giorni prima
ho avuto un altro piccolo problema una
vena del mio fegato
la vera principale si chiama bella porta
si è ristretta e quindi ora succede che
tengono al circolo bene bisogna
intervenire a 14 piccolo intervento
hanno infranto vicino e la pena così
questa ragazza è allargato e il sangue
andrò a circolare dopo 15 giorni torno a
casa tutto contento che perde uno
scandalo ma erano dovevo prendere una
piccola pacifica che di solito prenderò
gli anziani siamo sicuramente davide
sentivi guardare questo pasticca serve
per la collaborazione del sangue e cosa
succede al momento che ci si sbuccia
rimaniamo poi c'è una ferita di sangue
c'è molto di tutti non di semplice
taglio che potrebbe avere una persona
senza gomma e quindi ora succede per sei
mesi e non posso dare solo scampoli
perché vi sarebbero sei mesi per mettere
opportune sangue e terminare oggi il
boom di un altro dramma
pensavo di essere morto nuovamente
questa volta un giorno un pomeriggio un
pomeriggio d'inverno
ero in casa con il telefono è retaggio
youtube
volevo vedere un po di video sullo
skateboard come facciamo sempre
soltanto nella home per apparso un video
totalmente diverso di un molto
particolare c'era scritto nel titolo
gioco di magia con le carte quelli più
distratti lato come
quindi ho cliccato così per curiosità
pensate cosa fare credetemi trattati
email tre minuti più belli della mia
vita dalla rim ha iniziato a
documentarne studiare organizzato
intrapreso un percorso fino al giorno in
cui ho incontrato un amico
eh sì volta reti inventando ho
incontrato una persona no un amico non è
sempre aperta il mio miglior amico e
questo un mazzo di carte quindi ho
iniziato a studiare per ora ad
avventurarvi in questo mondo e ricordo
la prima volta che ho fatto un gioco di
magia a qualcuno faceva un pochino a
casa con i parenti però quella sicilia
si pongono è un giorno di cc dopo un
paio d'anni giudico magica di uscire
fuori e far vedere dice non sapevo fare
la prima sera portai fuori il mio mazzo
di carte della pasta nel giubbotto e
c'erano tutti i miei amici temi come
come si fa dice vedono roberto tasca e
ha tirato fuori un amante di l'art
l'ho rimesso dentro all'inizio non
fermarmi le mani ad aware non sopporterò
piccolo mi vergognavo
eccoli per quella sera un ace del tar e
la seconda vero aver infilato un mazzo
di carte nel giubbotto e far uscire di
nuovo con la serial è convinto a
pensarmi tragedia devo fare i giorni
anche la serata materia arrivato sono
uscito il mio maggio è anche quella
strana tremavano le mani
avevo proprio non so se ho paura di
essere presi in giro
comunque volevo fare gioco
quelli in cosa succede da terza sera
finalmente a un giubbotto tirò fuori la
scatolina hanno le carte e iniziative di
ragionare può collegare un amico sicilia
che fa è vero fangio io immagino cosa
faccio adesso la faccio adesso magari
prendi una volta fermato per di più
tardi perché ho fatto il gioco molto
semplice molto larino che avevo imparato
dopo iniziò a fare il gioco e alla fine
c'è un momento in cui faccio vedere
tutte le carte e una sola carta è girato
al contrario e sarebbe partito quella
nazione non mi scorderò mai con steno le
carte sul tavolo c'era una carta gila
non faccio il mazzo questo nemico non ha
neanche guardato la carta si è infilato
è dato io il fattore della carta per
contro la libia ma come fai e temo che
si erano sempre i cattivi sono
peggiorati come in questo questo grande
mondo
la serata costa non riuscito ad ottenere
ma noi li vedevano come file audio hi fi
e niente l'anno scorso ho provato a fare
un provino che andar male non era preso
la gara da ascoltare e anche lì pensavo
di aver perso molto una volta sconfitta
ed è per questo che quando si perde
quando si fallisce il pavimento è che
quando si allenti io non ho fallito
io sono riuscito a ritrovare sono tutto
qua e dopo un ultimo gioco amico lui a
scuola capita poi però quando andavo a
scuola l'anno scorso di vedere delle
persone disabili
sì assolutamente io e la mia storia con
un'operazione sono stato molto fortunato
e poi per impedire comunque cercato
fortuna rapita realtà l'operazione al
sociale al calcio
io sono un fatto molto fortunato quando
avremo imprenditore no
molte persone diano mamma mia che
sfortuna proprio altri poteva montare
invece l'altro con il venivano leo
segreta cazzo sei ragazza fortunata del
mondo
amenta c pensare perché stanno i ragazzi
purtroppo il mondo in modo per semplici
prima librarmi ho deciso ma numero sono
entrato nella sala operatoria e sono
uscito con gli scivoli e sono state due
giornate
c'era un bambino della fame che è uscito
è entrato ma dove ricevere dalla
pubblica tornare a penna su un giorno
nel portellone
ora sono qui questo modo milan non so di
me fai di voi voi dopo è tutto finito
questa bellissima giornata e poi uscite
con le persone in pelle mente labile e
per prendere in giro perché capitano che
intendiamo agire di lapidi io non so
reattivo ma a scuola capita in causa
disabile e senti il ragazzo ha grandi
beh molti pensano che questa tela in
giro chiamata perché il disabile presto
a noi oppure io volevo mentre il resto
da voi in questo momento nel momento in
cui ero gravi eh sì ero diverso e
disabili sono diversi da noi ma questo
perché perché tutti i disabili in questo
mondo sono migliori di voi perchè
mettete poi non ne parli loro c'era un
prete voi ad essere i disabili ad
accentrare la vita umana cioè condizioni
non pensano dell'auto è costretto a
stare su un calzino e tu puoi ammirare
per noi appena camminare fare questo è
normale
se vogliamo la tv conveniamo mandiamo a
giro che il john lennon
il design è più forti di noi perché è
riuscito accettare il mondo così com'è
quindi devo vedere quando i cicli fuori
da questa quest'aula quando avrete un
disabile a giro finisce nella mano e
sorrisi perché
tornando al discorso delle carte come
minimo
questa sera però volevo farmi vedere un
gioco
gli altri tutti sanno fare i giochi
magari vediamo in televisione dove
studiava quando le facciamo queste
semplici e volevo venire un po diverso
dagli altri ma ti volevo fare un gioco
che ci sono lì potevo fare ma non perché
poi ci teniamo perché la vera storia non
imponiamo la nostra diventa quindi ho
voluto mettere la mia storia dentro un
gioco di macero per questo siamo giacomo
vi farò vedere farofa di rilanciarmi e
tutti veramente la mia storia
frank miller e un mazzo di carte
bene pure tu ovviamente con oscillare
tra tutte quante può arrivare fuori
peter e io ti chiedo adesso di toccarne
una conta diverse solo toccare rendita o
camarda parlare della tutti acate è una
donna ai fiori esaltato in modo ti
lascia la nostra se invece voleva
merlano grandi viaggi noi è importante
questo gioco in cravatta piace questo
perché io
ho voluto sfogare un po le carte e so
che le caricano di significati
certo siamo altre carte anno d'estate la
domanda un significato il cavo
pacificato e io ho trovato una carta che
ha un significato gara significa la
domanda per il significato della donna
un compound con k ogni carta ha un
significato
voglio che questa sia l'unica carta
sopra questo dopo la scarpa in avola
c'è una carta che mi sta apparecchi al
cuore perché mi rispecchia musica questa
carta altro punto molto importante in
materia è l'asso di cuori
ti spiego un altro motivo ci sono andato
a cercare il significato della recovery
qual è il significato era che ad altre
parole il significato la prima in amore
grande parola amore di solito amore però
non è amore se c'è un po di ristoro
punto casa pallavolo l'amore l'amore se
prima non c'è un ragazzo di campo
harding e sace ragazzo difeso la ragazza
addio è caduta una donna una donna che
in questa parola è l'amore
come ho già detto che la ragazza nella
seconda parola è una parola molto
importante è riuscita se l'aspetta per
la riuscita è riuscita con il prof
ecco io la parola di uscita lascio con
me io faccio scegliere una carta e poi
ai suoi giovani potete vi sto per
parlare sto propri quadri io me ne
doveva fare devo mettere gli adeguati
all'interno del mezzo e devo riuscire a
trovarlo che sa come fare a trovarlo non
da solo lo svizzero appunto il ragazzo e
da ragazzo non possono vedere che si
trova a autorità di pregio le ragazze e
ragazzi a guardare wow
c'è solo una carta attraverso gli scappa
il bic per anomali pique e ovviamente è
tutto bellissimo
[Applauso]
[Musica]
bene rimane lo sgombero che non avrei
sperato nessuno si chiama rinascita 3
nasce una grande valore una bella parola
la società dopo le operazione dopo tutto
quello passato esoneriamo diciamo altra
persona oggi con un'altra passione con
altre delibere e devi sapere quando ho
scoperto che queste le parole dopo
averlo letto con amore riuscita
rinascita sembra diventato lo fece del
mondo tanto bene sul tavolo che canta
c'era prima
ovviamente adesso non ci penserebbe che
la tribù di
[Applauso]
grazie a un bando renato
[Musica]